[Music]
scientists have long suspected black
holes may be located at the center of
galaxies throughout the universe but
despite being deceptively simple to
describe mathematically black holes
present an enigma for imaging how do you
see an object that captures everything
and reflects nothing
working in parallel in a massive global
collaboration scientists have overcome
tremendous technical challenges to
reveal the first ever image of the
mysterious black hole at the center of
the milky way sagittarius a star is the
black hole at the center of our own
milky way galaxy but we had never had
actually direct evidence that it's a
black hole until today
when you see that ring you see that
shadow it really is like a dream coming
true science fiction turned into reality
[Music]
hidden by clouds of dust and
interference from our own atmosphere
black holes have traditionally been very
difficult to see from earth but recently
300 scientists working together across
20 countries as part of the event
horizon telescope began to probe some
prime suspects in our cosmic
neighborhood you need a telescope the
size of the earth in order to see
a black hole and
the technique is actually well known
it's called very long baseline
interferometry so it's not a single
telescope it's actually a network of
radio antennas we use telescopes on top
of mountains very tall mountains to get
past the earth's atmosphere and we
recorded a wavelength of about one
millimeter so this is pretty much the
highest radio wavelengths that reliably
can be observed from the surface of the
earth the signals arrive onto the
telescopes we time tag them we record
them onto hard disks and then we ship
these hard disks to correlation centers
which are supercomputers that then
combine the data together realign all
the signals between the telescopes and
create this virtual telescope the size
of the earth you might remember seeing
this image back in 2019 this was event
horizon telescope's first big release an
intergalactic snapshot of a massive
black hole in the m87 galaxy
two years later they released this an
even more detailed image of m87 that
revealed a spiraling magnetic field
swirling around the black hole it
confirmed in vivid color that the black
hole is forcing matter to move around it
and at light speeds we're looking at the
orbits of gas around the black hole
though the images from m87 dazzled the
world and proved the capabilities of the
event horizon telescope the scientists
had their sights set on a suspected
black hole much closer to home
sag a star in the constellation of
sagittarius
[Applause]
when i entered the field of radio
astronomy as a student i was told about
this enigma
this mysterious radio source cj star at
the heart of our galaxy it's very
exciting here today to show you this
best ever image of that enigma sergey
starr
[Music]
the similarities between these images is
fantastic and that's because we think
that black holes are described by just a
few parameters
these are punctures in space-time so
severe that it doesn't really matter how
you light up the black hole it's going
to appear
the same almost from any direction too
even though it's significantly smaller
in size than m87 sage star displays the
same telltale warping of space-time
predicted by einstein's theory of
general relativity offered over a
century ago this was a confirmation and
it was important confirmation because
when you see one black hole even though
the m87 result was extremely clear
seeing the second ring
really confirms it you know one is
promising two is now a certainty
black holes are destructive forces
because they also the graveyards of
stars but they may also have a creative
potential because they regulate star
formation as matter falls in they become
very energetic blow out gas and you know
their outflows may actually create
turbulence and distribute matter around
in the galaxy and so maybe some of the
elements of life that are inside us are
here today because our black hole was
more active in the past and was acting
like a big mixer and distributing
elements around the galaxy
in coming years the eht aims to link
together even more telescopes around the
world to increase the size of their
global array as they continue to probe
the deep and dark unknowns about black
holes a lot of the motivation we have
with the eht is that we're basically
opening a new laboratory to studying
these mysterious objects as far as open
questions we'd really i think like to
pin down some of the properties of these
black holes better getting the spin of a
black hole would be a major achievement
the next big questions for sagittarius a
star would be
can we make movies
can we resolve dynamics at the event
horizon
the modern technology lets us see black
holes and it makes you feel almost
omnipotent but then the same image tells
you where your limits are because you
never can overcome the event horizon it
tells you until here and no further
we know that we don't understand what
happens inside of a black hole that's
why i think people are interested in
black holes it's
they represent the deepest mysteries and
we're making inroads on them it also
gives me hope for the future there's so
many problems that face us as humans on
the planet that seem intractable and you
see the event horizon telescope succeed
and you have hope that we'll be able to
tackle these global questions together
[Music]
you